how's it going everybody back with
another update about the Avengers 4
trailer if you are not aware the
Avengers 4 trailer was supposed to come
out this Wednesday but it was delayed
due to the fact that the US government
named tomorrow December 5th a national
mourning day due to President Bush
passing away but no need to worry there
has been a report that the trailer will
actually come out this Friday instead
it's supposed to come out Friday at 9
a.m. and for those of you wondering
where to watch it don't worry Marvel
will upload it directly to YouTube this
report comes from Daniel RPK who was a
writer for Super bro movies daniel has
been right about many things in the past
and was right about the Captain Marvel
trailer releasing on Monday the trailer
coming out on Friday has also been
reported by Skyler Schuler Skyler is
editor in chief at the biz insider and a
writer for the hastag show there have
been other reports as well from people
who have been write about these things
in the past so all the reports say that
the trailer has been changed from
Wednesday to Friday I know it stinks
that we're not getting it tomorrow but
things change especially when it comes
to a former President of the United
States passing away I understand many of
you are not from the United States but
Disney's headquarters is in the United
States and tomorrow has been declared by
the US government a national mourning
day so the trailer has been moved from
Wednesday to Friday and this actually
makes a lot of sense because we got the
Captain Marvel trailer on Monday the
game Awards are Thursday and the
spider-man far from home trailer is
rumored to come out on Saturday and
obviously nothing is happening on
Wednesday due to Bush's funeral and you
would assume that they would want the
Avengers 4 trailer out before the
spider-man far from home trailer because
Spidey is technically dust right now so
maybe the Avengers 4 trailer could
possibly clear some things up for us if
it's more than a teaser trailer I know
everybody including myself is getting
very impatient but we're so close the
trailer was supposed to be here tomorrow
on Wednesday it has only been delayed
once due to President Bush's funeral and
has been reported to come out Friday and
although it hasn't been stated by Marvel
it has been stated by very reliable
sources so stay tuned I will keep you
up-to-date with anything that I hear
concerning the trailer as always thank
you all so much for watching
Worf
[Music]